to the only thing i ever knew i wanted
to be
and family
green lights january 22
1989 titled i've found myself
questioned the most difficult word in
the universe who what where when how
and that's the truth why is even bigger
i ask
i think i'll write a book a word about
my life i wonder who would give a damn
about the pleasure and the stripe
i think i'll write a book help the
generations with the truth about the
past
who's to say one word of grace [ __ ] i'm
tired
i hope that these thoughts last i shall
think i will write a book
mood for the sayings favorite one
psychological let life be
no then we are cowards if we let it be
just write a book
it's from one of my journals january 22
1989
on with this book i titled green light
here we go
this is not a traditional memoir yes i
tell stories from the past but i have no
interest in nostalgia since mentality or
the retirement that most memoirs require
this is not an advice book either
although i like preachers i'm not here
to preach and tell you what to do
this is an approach book i am here to
share stories
insights and philosophies that can be
objectively understood
and if you choose subjectively adopted
by either changing your reality
or changing how you see it
this is a playbook based on adventures
in my life
adventures that have been significant
enlightening and funny
sometimes because they were meant to be
but mostly because they did not try to
be
look i'm an optimist by nature and humor
has been one of my great teachers
it has helped me deal with pain loss and
lack of trust i am not perfect no i
step in [ __ ] all the time and recognize
it when i do
i've just learned how to scrape it off
my boots and carry on
because we all stepping [ __ ] from time
to time we hit roadblocks we [ __ ] up we
get [ __ ] we get sick we don't get what
we
want we cross thousands of could have
done betters and wish that wouldn't have
happened tonight
stepping in [ __ ] is inevitable so let's
either see it as good luck
or figure out how to do it less often
to life i've been in this life for 50
years
trying to work out it's riddle for 42
and keeping diaries of clues to that
riddle for the last 35
notes about successes and failures joys
and sorrows things that made me
marvel and things that made me laugh out
loud 35 years of realizing
remembering recognizing gathering and
jotting down what has moved me
or turned me on along the way how to be
fair
how to have less stress how to have fun
how to hurt people less how to get hurt
less how to be a good man
how to get what i want how to have
meaning in life how to be
more me now i never wrote these things
down to remember
i always wrote things down so i could
forget the idea of revisiting my life in
musings was a daunting one
i wasn't sure if i'd enjoy the company
recently i worked up the courage to sit
down with those diaries
and have a look at the 35 years of
writing about who i've been over the
last 50.
and you know what i enjoyed myself more
than i thought i would
i laughed i cried i realized i had
remembered
more than i expected and forgot less
what did i find i found stories i
witnessed and experienced
lessons i learned and forgot poems
prayers prescriptions
answers to questions i had reminders of
questions i still have
affirmations for certain doubts beliefs
about what matters theories on
relativity
and a whole bunch of bumper stickers i
found consistent ways that i approached
life that gave me more satisfaction
at the time and still i found a reliable
theme
so i packed up those journals and took a
one-way ticket to solitary confinement
in the desert
where i began writing what you hear now
an album a record a story of my life so
far
things i witness dream chased gave and
received truth bombs that interrupted my
space and time in ways i could not
ignore
contracts i have made with myself many
of which i live up to
most of which i still pursue these are
my sights and scenes felt and figured
out cools and shamefuls
grace's truths and beauties of brutality
initiations invitations calibrations and
graduations getting away with getting
caught and getting wets trying to dance
between the raindrops
rights of passage all between her on the
other side of persistence and letting go
on the way
to the science of satisfaction in this
great experiment called life
hopefully it's medicine that tastes good
a couple of aspirin instead of the
infirmary
a spaceship to mars without needing your
pilot's license
going to church without having to be
born again and laughing through the
tears
it's a love letter to life
now speaking of bumper stickers i have
always loved bunker stickers
so much so that i've stuck bumper to
sticker and made them one word
bumper sticker they're lyrics one-liners
quick hitters
unobtrusive personal preferences that
people publicly express
they're cheap and they're fun they don't
have to be politically correct because
well they're just bumper stickers from
the font they're in to the color scheme
to the word or words they say
a bumper sticker tells you a lot about
the person behind the wheel in front of
you
their political views if they've got a
family or not if they're free spirits or
conformist
funny or serious what kind of pets they
have what kind of music they like
even what their religious beliefs might
be over the last 50 years i've been
collecting my bumper stickers
some i've seen some i've heard some i
stole some my dreams some i said
some are funny some are serious but they
all stuck with me
because that's what bumper stickers do
i've included quite a few of my
favorites in this book
the sole objective is the pursuit of the
singular finish with only the arrival
in sight this is what brings us together
sometimes you gotta go back to go
forward and i don't mean going back
to reminisce or chase ghost i mean go
back to see where you came from where
you've been how you got
here that's me from lincoln at in 2014
you might remember that one it got
parodied quite a bit
sold a lot of cars too
so how did i get here
well i've earned a few scars getting
through this rodeo of humanity
i've been good at it i've been not so
good at it and ultimately i've found
some pleasure in all of it
either way here are some facts about me
to help set the table
i am the youngest brother of three and
the son of parents who were twice
divorced and thrice married to
each other we grew up saying i love you
to each other
we meant it i got whipped until my butt
bled for putting on a cracker jack
tattoo when i was 10 years old
when i first threatened to run away from
home my parents packed my bags for me
my dad wasn't there the day i was born
he called my mom and said
only thing i have to say is if it's a
boy don't name him kelly
the only thing i ever knew i wanted to
be in life was a father
i learned to swim when my mom threw me
in the llano river and i was either
going to float off the rocky waterfall
30 yards downstream
or make it back to the bank i made it to
the bank
i was always the first one to wear out
the knees and my tough skin jeans
for two years i led the under 12 soccer
league in red cards
as a goalie when i kept whining about my
lone pair of tennis shoes being old and
out of fashion
my mom told me keep griping and i'll
take you to meet the boy with no feet
i was blackmailed into having sex for
the first time when i was 15.
i was certain i was going to hell for
the premarital sex
today i am merely certain that i hope
that's not the case i was molested by a
man when i was 18 while knocked
unconscious in the back of a van
i've done peyote in reality couture say
mexico in a cage with a mountain lion
i've had 78 stitches sewn into my
forehead by a veterinarian
i've had four concussions from falling
out of four trees three of them
on a full moon i have bongoed naked
until the cops arrested me
i have resisted arrest i applied to duke
university of texas at austin southern
methodist and grambling for my college
education
i got accepted to three out of four i've
never felt like a victim
i have a lot of proof that the world is
conspiring to make me happy
i've always gotten away with more in my
life than in my dreams
i've had many people give me poems that
i did not know i wrote
i've been naive evil and ascenic but i'm
most fearless in my belief
of my and mankind's benevolence and the
common denominator of the values among
us
i believe the truth is only offensive
when we're lying
i was raised on existential outlaw logic
a carnation of malaprops
full of fictitious physics because if it
wasn't true
it ought to be
there was nothing fictitious about the
love though the love was real
bloody sometimes but never in question
i learned early on how to get relative
how to deal
i learned resilience consequences
responsibility
and how to work hard i learned how to
love laugh forgive forget play
and pray i learned how to hustle sell
charm turn the tide make a downfall my
up falling spinny yarn
i learned how to navigate highs and lows
hugs and blows assets and deficits love
songs and epithets
especially when faced with the
inevitable this is a story about getting
relative
with the inevitable this is a story
about green lights
the arrival is inevitable death
a unanimous end a unified destination a
noun without regard
our eulogy written and lived
the approach is relative life a singular
procession
our personal journey a verb with regard
our resume write it live it
this is the first 50 years of my life of
my resume so far
on the way to my eulogy
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you